hi there welcome to metaphysical
milkshake i'm marine wilson
and i'm reza haslam
hey
hey what's wrong you know ryan i don't
know man i've been cooped up in this
house for two years with this damn
pandemic and i'm
i'm telling you man i'm i'm ready to i'm
ready to get out there and have some fun
i'm just miserable all the time now wow
okay i'm up for that reza what do you
want to do you want to play some online
uh
dungeons and dragons over zoom or
something no i don't want to do that
again i want to do something crazy i
want to like
experience the roaring 20s man i want to
go hang gliding i want to like jump out
of an airplane when is burning man
okay wait wait well slow slow your roll
aslan
listen take it easy you've got four kids
right okay
instead of that
you you've got your own kind of
you've got your own kind of burning man
roaring twenties right at home enjoy
your four kids isn't it better to just
stay at home with them
no man i'm i'm bored of paw patrol i
want to go out there and like like
experience it i want like i want
pleasure i want pleasure all the time
okay all right yep okay i see what's
going on here
what what is it what's going on
uh didn't a certain someone who shall
remain nameless just finished a certain
non-fiction book they've been working on
for nearly a year and a half and handed
it in to their publisher this week
i mean more like two years but yes i
finished my book what's your point
and didn't a certain somebody feel a
rush of joy euphoria and freedom when
they did said accomplishment
yeah yeah i felt absolutely terrific
yeah and now
uh does that certain someone have some
feelings that are starting to slowly
subside
and is this unnamed person starting to
now feel
miserable
so [ __ ] miserable
and uh
you'd be willing to
bring that joy back any way you possibly
can
i'll literally do anything yeah
don't you see reza you're addicted to
dopamine
you got a taste of the big d and you
want more man no don't please
don't say it like that okay my wife
listens to this podcast you love big d
you love big d
dopamine
you took a swing on the dope rope rez
you got a front row seat but the dopa
cabana and sinatra is performing you
know
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
[Music]
oh my god
okay i'm addicted to dopamine wait wait
but that's not a bad thing right like i
mean
isn't dopamine like the pleasure no
chemical don't worry don't worry it's
not your fault okay oh my god i think
you're right i'm
i think i'm addicted to the dopamine hey
hey hey slow down now come on it's not
your fault it's not no no no
we're all addicted to dopamine okay
okay but that's not how is that a bad
thing though like isn't dopamine like
the pleasure chemical ah but there's the
rub my friend there ain't no such thing
as pleasure without pain you feel me
wait a minute wait a minute are you
saying
that the reason we're all so miserable
all the time is because we're all
addicted to the thing that makes us less
miserable
exactly it's a conundrum or rather
it's a dopanundrum
so here to discuss said quandary
is
the stanford
therapist scientist
raconteur
dr anna lemke author of dopamine nation
yup she's a specialist in the
opioid epidemic in the united states
she's also the author of drug dealer md
that's one of my favorite favorite book
titles of all time how doctors were
duped patients got hooked and why it's
so hard to stop
she got her undergraduate degree at yale
and her md at stanford this new book is
new york times bestseller and she even
appeared in the 2020 netflix documentary
the social dilemma which i saw and
changed the way that i think about
social media so thank you
dr lemke
welcome to the show dr anna lemke
okay milkshakers we've got anna lemke
right here hi anna how are you
hi i'm good so nice to see you
this book was a revelation i loved it so
much it's gotten me thinking on so many
different levels dopamine nation finding
balance
in the age of indulgence cannot
recommend it more highly let's start
like we're being shot out of a cannon
what the [ __ ] is dopamine
and really how is it different than
pleasure itself
so dopamine is a chemical that we make
in our brain
it is essential to the experience of
pleasure motivation and reward
the fundamental difference between
things that are reinforcing that is to
say addictive and those that are not
is that things that are reinforcing
release a whole lot more dopamine all at
once
in a part of the brain called the reward
pathway
however
dopamine shouldn't just be equated with
the experience of pleasure dopamine is
also released in response to things that
are novel new or different dopamine can
even be released in response to aversive
or painful stimuli if the volume is
turned up really high on those so really
the best way to think of dopamine
is that it is about pleasure motivation
and reward but it's also
an important signal
for us to
be aware of changes in our immediate
environment that are fundamental to our
survival
i found this absolutely fascinating
uh that because i'm one of those people
who just assumed that dopamine was
um you know pleasure itself like
but
you you make this very interesting
distinction that
dopamine
actually motivates us to do things that
we think will bring us pleasure right
it's not just like it does it's not a a
pleasure stimulant it it motivates us to
go out there and try to do things that
we think
uh will bring us pleasure can you help
us understand kind of the difference
between those two things
right so the classic experiment is that
scientists engineered a group of rats to
have no dopamine transmission
and what they discovered with those rats
is that if they put food in the rat's
mouth the rat would eat the food swallow
it and even seem to get pleasure from it
as much as you can tell that from a rat
eating food
i'm actually quite adept at uh
noticing rat pleasure but go on good
good i'm glad
but if you take that food and you place
it a mere body length away from the rat
the rat will starve to death it can't
even be bothered to get up to go get
that food
and that was really the clue to
scientists that hey dopamine is
important for pleasure
things like euphoria but it's also
really important to the experience of
motivation to go get the reward and
maybe even more important to that
phenomenon so if you're if you're taking
a bite of a doughnut
are you getting dopamine
is the dopamine the pleasure of like oh
that's a crispy sweet donut or is the
dopamine that but also like you should
eat more donuts or you should have
donuts every day or you should eat more
sweet crunchy things every day like how
how exactly does that add up yes okay so
we have been wired over millions of
years of evolution to approach pleasure
and avoid pain and one of the main brain
signals that we get to get us to do that
approach pleasure and avoid pain is
dopamine we're always firing dopamine at
a tonic baseline but the deviation from
that baseline either above the baseline
or below the baseline is really
fundamental to understanding the role of
dopamine so getting to your question
when i bite into a really delicious
donut
you know i have a sensory taste
experience that goes immediately to my
brain that goes to the part of the brain
called the reward pathway and that
releases dopamine because sugar is
inherently reinforcing for almost
everybody so
then
i say to myself oh wow that was
pleasurable
i want to do it again right so we that
we lay down memory
for that that experience for our initial
reaction to that stimulus it's a very
powerful memory the more pleasurable the
experience the more powerful the memory
and then yes i want to repeat that
experience in the future now i want to
qualify that by saying that
people are different in terms of what
gives them intense pleasure there is
this concept of drug of choice so what
might be really reinforcing for you
might not be that reinforcing for me and
vice versa
but what i find fascinating though is
that we're at the stage now where we can
actually
measure right the amount of dopamine
that you get from whatever the pleasure
activity is uh in fact um according to
this research so
chocolate
can increase our dopamine above baseline
by about 50 percent
and sex can do it at about a hundred
percent which i love i love the idea
that sex is just twice as good as
chocolate that's it now we know
exactly how much better sex is than
chocolate twice as good everyone
well let me qualify that for a second it
was it was an experiment in rats and it
was actually you know
in units just it's sort of dopamine to
sort of become the current wait a minute
how did they get the rats to smoke the
cigarettes
yes so they didn't smoke the cigarettes
they delivered nicotine intravenously i
know that that's which by the way gives
you a hundred and fifty percent nikki i
love the idea of rats
yeah they hand them a lit cigarettes and
rats like right yeah that was a great
screen chilling chilling
um
so but i but it's it's important i think
to point out that that it is an
experiment in rats it's not in humans
because we don't stick probes in
people's brains to measure their
dopamine levels in real time what we do
in humans is actually neuroimaging
studies that can show us
at a more
let's say a less specific level that
indeed that part of the pathway
the reward pathway is lighting up and
give us some sense of
the intensity of the dopamine stimulus
and i think that's important to point
out because
again this concept of drug of choice is
really important like sex might be
really really reinforcing for me but for
you chocolate might be better
dr lemke you you tell these incredible
stories throughout the book so it's not
just kind of this data
um incredible stories from your
therapeutic practice
um
the one that you you start off with a
bang no pun intended so to speak with uh
a man who continually over the course of
his life invents
masturbation machines yes um
which by the way um he should be
marketing
but
also also people you don't need a
machine
i mean i don't know when you read the
story you're kind of like yeah no i know
the machine it sounds horrific and it
caused this person no end of humiliation
and pain throughout his life so i don't
i feel even bad joking about it and you
have the teenage girl who has gotten so
addicted to pot and marijuana which by
the way people think like that's not
addictive at all i know so many people
that have been
really truly addicted to it um but doing
a gram a day like that's just a ton of
like just animals and
these stories of addiction in the
extreme that you've dealt with uh in
your practice it seems like all the time
and
one of the things you talk about
throughout the book that's really
interesting is there's a
i don't want to say this the wrong way
it seems like you have a certain
admiration for these addicts in a way
where you're rather you kind of you flip
the switch you flip the story a little
bit to say here are people that will go
to incredible lengths
in their lives
they'll they'll set up you know a
masturbation machine it'll take days
weeks months to build in order to get
a few lousy minutes of dopamine high
you seem in a way to
you identify with the addicts you you
empathize with them and in some ways you
kind of admire them and their efforts
and i'd love to hear your personal
connection to that and and and
bottom line like what role does dopamine
play in addiction
um
well let me start by saying that you
know i've been treating addiction for
more than 20 years and i can honestly
say that i feel like i've learned more
from my patients than they've learned
from me
i think that people in recovery from
severe addiction are modern day heroes
and also modern day prophets they're
absolutely amazing people who
demonstrate tremendous courage in the
face of incredible
adversity and when they come out the
other side they really are repositories
for so much wisdom and i think
um especially at this time you know in
history
um exactly the kind of wisdom that we
need so my you know i do not see
addiction as an otherness
i really see us as all vulnerable to
addiction in the modern age where
feel-good drugs and behaviors are
universal unlimited
and infinitely accessible
and so
people with addiction in recovery can
really guide the way and provide road
maps for the rest of us for navigating
this dopamine overloaded world and their
stories in particular their lived
experience really is is a powerful
powerful guide because if they can do it
in this crazy world that we live in then
surely the rest of us
can do it
i would also say that um
you know when when jacob my patient with
a very severe uh
sex addiction came to see me
he happened to come about
well i think three to five years
after i myself had um overcome a mild
addiction
to romance novels
and
um when i met him and i heard his story
you know certainly there was a part of
me and i talk about in this in the book
that was like horrified right that he'd
gone to such lengths and then i just
realized like in a flash you know what
that could have been me i mean that
totally could have been me in a way it
was me because i had my own
machine of sorts which was this you know
electronic device this kindle that gave
me this access to all of these romance
novels that progressed over time to
frank erotica and i was using it in a
self and other destructive way so really
it was his case that sort of
crystallized
something i'd been wanting to
communicate and had difficulty
communicating until i met him and i also
want to just say thank you jacob for
having the courage and the generosity to
share your story with readers
because um you know without that the
book wouldn't be possible and i've um
you know told him many times since the
book was published how much he's helped
people and it's been really positive
experience for him him too
rain uh i don't know if you know this
about me but uh this year i turned 50.
whoa
yeah i know whoa imagine i'm like an old
man graham aslan
i'm gonna i'm gonna need like you know
lower prescription costs i want to be
worried about that stuff i'll be talking
about reverse mortgages all the time i
may even even have to join
the aarp
well uh
too slow bro i already joined the aarp
for for real legit i'm 56 i am a card
carrying member and when i say card
carrying member i literally have an aarp
card in my pocket i'm so psyched to use
it and listen there's so many reasons to
join aarp as we get older we're more
concerned about affordable health care
lower prescription costs protecting
social security and medicare aarp
advocates for you and offers financial
aid and job resources fraud protection
help
information on joining local volunteer
groups and much much more because aarp
knows you've got a lot
of good years ahead there's commercial
benefits folks 61 average savings on
prescription drugs not covered by
medicare and up to 15 off meals at
participating restaurants i'm looking at
you denny's
so try the benefits yourself go to
aarp.org
milkshake to join for just twelve
dollars for your first year with
automatic renewal you'll get a second
membership for free plus aarp the
magazine and a free
gift
that is aarp.org
milkshake
i think a lot of people are wondering
whether cbd actually works like is it a
real thing well let me put it this way
over 90 percent of doctors said that
their patients have used cbd
to treat some health condition or
another listen
when nine out of 10 patients
are using cbd that speaks volumes about
how safe and effective cbd
can be so let me tell you about
cbdistillery.com
with over 2 million customers cb
distillery is the source that i trust
when patients tell the doctors that they
use cbd for help with their health
conditions
what are some of those conditions rain
you're a big fan of the cbd i do
well
the main thing is is sleep so sometimes
i get kind of anxious at night my brain
is spinning and i'm just lying there or
sometimes i'll just
i'll go to sleep and i'll just wake up
like 45 minutes later like wide awake as
if my body thought it was a nap
and
uh cbd oil um
it really helps with uh sleep so if you
haven't discovered the power of cbd
you're missing out go to
cbdistillery.com where you order online
with no prescription required and enter
milkshake for 20 off again enter
milkshake for 20 off at cbdistillary.com
that's cbdistillery.com
not available in idaho iowa and south
dakota
yeah it it it this is why the book is so
successful it grounds the science but it
also as a reader so engages your heart
because you just feel for these people
and their struggle and it helps
you know for you know i've had addiction
issues from my life
alcohol other things and um
but for people that don't haven't
experienced that it's it's a pretty
alien concept why don't you just stop
right but these stories allow you to see
like you know how deep the rabbit hole
goes you know to quote the matrix
yes and i think for me for most of my
life and career
i didn't
did i thought i didn't have the
addiction gene i really did because like
i'd never been addicted to anything
substances i've tried tried that other
people said were great i'm like i don't
get it but the truth was i just hadn't
yet encountered my drug of choice and
then along came the internet and along
came e-readers and for whatever reason i
hadn't really read a romance novel in my
life until middle age but i read the
twilight saga and i was gone and i was
off and running for the next two years
and it was kind of crazy like i kind of
woke up from it at some point and i
talked about in the book sort of how i
did but i was like wow i think i just
got addicted to romance novels but it
happened insidiously
um and it's so funny you bring that up
because one of my other heroes dr gabor
mate talks about his kind of addiction
with record consuming you know
shopaholic for record albums and his
collection of thousands of record albums
that he's never even opened or listened
to but he has to have them
and uh
and
this is kind of sidebar conversation but
um
you know his his thesis is a little
different than yours his is that
addiction really comes from childhood
trauma and it has a direct correlation
um i don't think you're negating what
he's saying at all but what are your
thoughts on uh his viewpoint and so many
other people that are addiction
specialists that you know if you treat
the childhood trauma portion of the
addiction that that is that is better
than just kind of like doing anything
that remotely seems like putting a
band-aid on the addiction itself or
dealing with the addiction itself
yes so i certainly you know as a
psychiatrist believe in understanding
where we've come from and trying to
piece together those especially early
childhood
milestones so that we can truly see
you know
how and why
we cope in the way that we cope we see
things the way that we see you know like
our sort of underlying
you know maladaptive strategies
but i do think that it's possible to
spend too much time there
and that sometimes people who have like
the ideal childhood and
great families and partners and the
perfect job and
great social networks like those people
can get addicted to
so even in the absence of you know a
trauma like
there's the physiologic
biologic
piece of it that is incredibly powerful
that doesn't require um another
explanation
i also think that sometimes
you know perseverating about like well
what caused my addiction can actually
delay making progress with the addiction
you know
as might one of my patients put it very
well sometimes insight is the booby
prize
um and you know just because we
understand or think we understand you
know why we do this maladaptive behavior
it doesn't necessarily lead to
our ability to change that behavior so
um
that's why i really think it's important
again to to move sort of to
appreciate the impact of trauma but to
sort of move beyond it
i will also say that i have seen
real harm done on the extreme end
where um you know some mental health
care providers
actually
get to a point where they're like
colluding with patients to find the
trauma including trauma that doesn't
really exist
um and so i think that this kind of
over emphasis on that piece of it can be
harmful
i think that when you were younger you
were probably molested by a vampire
it's possible it's possible
um i i love the way that you're you're
talking about this and it's such a
fascinating way of thinking about how
addiction works but more to the point of
the book so what exactly
is the role that dopamine plays in
fostering addictions you have this whole
fascinating section here about sort of
the relationship between pleasure and
pain and you use uh the kind of metaphor
of a seesaw right that they're like on
you know that your brain is a seesaw and
there's pleasure on one side and pain on
the other side and and when you sort of
do something to give pleasure your brain
naturally wants to kind of
you know stabilize the seesaw again and
bring up pain and it's such a
fascinating way of thinking about not
just the relationship between those two
things but how dopamine
which the purpose of which is to make us
seek pleasure
can end up causing so much pain
unnecessarily uh talk talk us through
that what what's the what what exactly
is the role that dopamine plays in
fostering the kinds of addiction that
you were talking about
so
to me one of the most exciting findings
in neuroscience in the last 100 years or
so is that
pain and pleasure are co-located in the
brain
which means that the same parts of the
brain that process pleasure also process
pain and they work like opposite sides
of a balance so imagine that there's a
balance like a a teeter-totter in a
kid's playground or a board on a fulcrum
in the part of your brain called the
reward pathway a part that has been
conserved over millions of years of
evolution
is similar across species it hasn't
changed it's vital for survival
and this balance represents how we
process pleasure and pain when we
experience something pleasurable it tips
to the pleasure side something painful
it tips to the pain side but one of the
overarching rules governing this balance
is that it wants to remain level it
doesn't want to be tipped for very long
to the side of pleasure or pain and in
fact the biological definition of stress
is any deviation from this neutral
baseline which scientists call
homeostasis
the way
that our balance restores homeostasis or
a level balance after a deviation is by
tilting an equal and opposite amount to
whatever the initial stimulus was
before going back to level so for
example when i eat a wrong when i when i
read a romance novel right dopamine is
released in my reward pathway my balance
tipped to the side of pleasure i feel
good but no sooner has that happened
then my brain adapts to increased
dopamine and i imagine that is these
little neuro adaptation gremlins hopping
on the pain side of my balance to bring
it level again but the gremlins like it
on the balance so they don't get off
when it's level they stay on until i'm
tipped an equal an amount
equal an opposite amount to the side of
pain and that's that
come down or that after effect or that
moment of
you know
right when i finish one chapter like not
wanting to put it away because i don't
want to feel
that come down right i don't want to
feel
that balance tilted the side pain so i
so i keep reading but here's the other
important rule governing this balance
with repeated exposure to the same or
similar stimulus that initial response
to pleasure gets weaker and shorter but
that after response gets stronger and
longer so the gremlins get stronger they
get more numerous
they get muscles right
and that means that over time if i
continue to read romance novels for days
to weeks to months to years which is
what i did i end up with enough gremlins
on the pain side of the balance to fill
this whole room now i'm in addicted
brain because what that means is that
i need my drug not to feel good but just
to restore balance and feel normal
when i'm not using i'm walking around
with a balance tilted to the side of
pain i'm in a dopamine deficit state
that means other things aren't
interesting my husband's not that
interesting my kids aren't that
interesting my work's not that
interesting right
um and i need ever more potent forms
right i started with twilight but i
ended up with 50 shades of grey why
because i got a lot a lot more gremlins
to counterbalance
and this is really
why why people relapse even after
they've stopped using for sustained
periods of time even after so much is
better in their lives it's because
they're walking around with that balance
tilted to the side of pain the universal
symptoms of withdrawal from any
addictive substance are anxiety
irritability insomnia depression and
intrusive thoughts of wanting to use
otherwise known as craving
see what i find so fascinating about
that what you just said
is that yes it makes it makes a lot of
sense on the individual level in fact i
think you know even before i'd heard you
say this you know just anecdotal
evidence about you know crashing from a
high or whatever like we've all had that
experience so we kind of intuitively
understand the the seesaw you know
metaphor
um
but when you expand it to the societal
level
suddenly so many things start to make
sense because like our entire
uh
contemporary society has been about
mitigating pain like we have the ability
now
to make sure you don't feel pain
right right physical pain emotional pain
we can handle all of it
but then why is it that as a society
we're more miserable now than we've ever
been
not because things are making us
necessarily more miserable although
there's plenty of things making us more
miserable
but because we are so adept now at
bringing us pleasure
that
we're it balances right the gremlins
show up
so
you know i don't ever have to be bored
anymore i don't ever have to have any
physical
pain
if i have like emotional distress i can
take care of that either with a pill or
with netflix right right uh you know i
don't ever have to be lonely because i
have my phone with me
so like
all i can give myself pleasure whenever
i want to
and the
inevitable consequence to that
is that i am making myself more
miserable right right the reason we're
all so miserable is because we've gotten
so good at avoiding being miserable that
just blows my mind
folks is your company or business having
a tough time hiring the people you need
i mean the producers at milkshake don't
know this but we're about to fire all of
them and we're desperate for
good competent employees and listen
we're at a time right now where
companies regardless of what size they
are whether we're talking about a coffee
shop or like a retail store they just
cannot keep up with hiring right now
there are 46 percent more jobs being
posted than before the pandemic and
they're 44
fewer candidates applying to those jobs
so you need to find the right candidates
and hire them fast workable can help
workable accelerates every step of your
hiring process from find to higher
workable helps you cast the widest net
possible by posting your jobs to all the
top job boards that's more than 200
total with just one click
it helps you evaluate and hire quickly
with modern tools like
video interviews and e-signatures
and workable will help you automate
repetitive tasks like scheduling
interviews so you can spend your time on
what's important making hires so whether
you're hiring for your coffee shop or
your engineering team
work your podcast or your podcast
workable is exactly what you need to
hire the right people fast start hiring
today with a risk-free 15-day trial if
you hire during the trial which many do
it won't cost a thing just go to
workable.com to start hiring workable is
hiring made easy
yeah
yeah you're absolutely right and you
know for me it's been 20
plus years of
seeing patients coming in
and more and more often seeing people
who have really everything you could
ever want
you know good partners good friends good
jobs good health and yet they have pain
from the tips of their eyelashes to the
tips of their toes
with no identifiable cause they're
depressed they're anxious they can't get
out of bed in the morning they feel
guilty on top of feeling
bad right
and
this is exactly i think it just sort of
dawned on me one day gosh you know
i think it's possible that
of course there are many causes for for
distress in the modern world but i began
to think that
perhaps at the core of some of our
suffering
is the fact that we're constantly
bombarding our reward pathway with these
tiny hits of dopamine and that the
cumulative effect over time is that
we've put ourselves in this dopamine
deficit state so when we use it feels
like you know
self-medication but really all it's
doing is driving the continued suffering
and if you look epidemiologically i mean
data points to support this are
that
the richest countries have the highest
rates of anxiety depression and suicide
um the richest countries have the
highest rates of addiction and we're
seeing addiction now in demographic
groups that were previously
relatively insulated so for example
alcohol use disorder has increased 85
percent in women in the past 30 years
and 50 in in people over the age of 65.
if you look at 70 percent of global
deaths are due to diseases caused by
modifiable risk factors and the top
three risk factors are
inactivity
smoking and poor diet so we've really
reached this tipping point where we're
essentially titillating titillating
ourselves to death wow there's there's
so much to unpack
in what you just said i have so many
questions that have popped up so let me
see great i love it i think you need to
repeat that last thing that you said
because this is this i was when i was
reading through
the book and then this prep document for
this interview i was astonished by that
statistic about the number of deaths
that are caused from
inactivity overeating
uh obesity cigarette smoking behaviors
that can be that are modifiable right um
but for so what role does dopamine play
in the fact that we are not modifying
those behaviors is it just an addiction
to a dopamine
that gives us an addiction to cigarettes
or an addiction to eating those donuts
that is that is killing us
so i don't usually talk about it as an
addiction to dopamine because to me
dopamine is it's just a signal right
yeah we're not actually addicted it just
serves a per it serves a very valuable
purpose right it keeps us alive that's
right yeah exactly without desire we
wouldn't bother to get up and do
anything so we need it and it's
important and it's it's the it's the
relative nature of it you know
and so when we're talking about you know
the growing numbers of global deaths
that are due to things like obesity and
smoking and in inactivity
you know we're talking about the fact
that
we have reached now this this tipping
point really where
for
many people across the world we have our
basic survival needs met
and yet
we're not flourishing
and part of why we're not flourishing is
because of this mismatch between our
primitive wiring and our modern
ecosystem
we are surrounded by so many
opportunities
for increased dopamine
that we are essentially at war with our
gremlins right we're bombarding
our brains with dopamine in ways large
and small throughout any given day all
of us all of us
and in order to try to compensate for
this fire hose of dopamine we have to
down regulate our own dopamine
production and our own dopamine
transmission and so we're all in this
kind of you know dopamine deficit state
and that again is a state of anxiety
irritability insomnia dysphoria craving
completely below the level of
consciousness or awareness it's very
very subtle
we're such fragile creatures at the end
of the day so susceptible to this
phenomenon not able to see true cause
and effect
without effort and so we're walking
around like i think more unhappy you
know more unhappy
um and
and
how is this affecting us during the
pandemic
well interesting so during the pandemic
like everybody's online more so people
getting more addicted to all of the
online drugs that exist and there are
too many to count
um people not having to you know
actually get up and commute to work so
more likely to drink
so alcohol sales went up alcohol
consumption went up because you know
people didn't have to really get it
together the next morning and that's
that's a that's something that gets
people to not consume right if you gotta
show up and give your a game you're
gonna kinda think about you know
what impact drinking alcohol the night
before might have on that
um
so certainly you know digital products
uh consumption of substances
very sadly drug overdoses which had just
started to decline in 2018 surged again
all-time highs over a hundred thousand
drug overdoses in this country between
march 2020 and march 2021 so sad so
tragic some of that is due to the um the
supply chain phenomenon and people not
having access to their usual supply and
then having an adulterated supply or
losing tolerance and so using more than
they could actually tolerate some of
it's just the progression of addiction
so really we have the phenomenon where
people who are already addicted
got worse some of them died people who
were sort of borderline addicted got
addicted but i just want to qualify all
that by saying
a lot of my patients
loved sheltering in place and got a lot
better during covid
because
it slowed their lives down
they weren't constantly being tempted by
parties by you know the liquor aisle at
the grocery store
by
you know all their friends getting
together and doing this that and the
other more time to exercise more time
with family so i think it's important to
acknowledge that for some people
quarantine and shelter in place was
actually a positive
so do you remember um grace jones had a
an album in the
late 70s early 80s called slave to the
rhythm
i remember grace jones i don't remember
that album well
i'm a slave to the algorithm
i truly am like
whoever invents algorithms like they do
such a masterful job like i was reading
this article about how the makers i
think it's called king
and they're in sweden and they make um
candy crush and they have psychologists
on staff
so that you can increase the dopamine
when you line up all your little candies
and it goes
it just makes you feel like oh that's so
good i solved that and you just feel
that and they and they so they literally
do that at the end and then they want
you to kind of spend the money to buy
that
extra tokens that allow you more lives
or more chances or or what have you i
had to i was playing candy crush i had
to take candy crush off my phone yeah
because i was just two oh and i i was on
level like 347
and then realizing like wait a second
i'm spending weeks have passed and i
have not left the house i have spent at
87 hours on these with these stupid
swedish candies and then
and then
you know i had to take social media off
my phone because i was just like
scrolling and poking and then they have
the same thing there psychologists on
staff helping develop these algorithms
so that you just swipe and scroll and
respond and blue blue blood you can ask
reza about that he's very very familiar
with how that works
don't out me and then all right and then
finally
finally anna and i relate to your
romance novel thing i had to take the
apple news app off my phone because i
was scrolling news and even the news has
an algorithm like if you read here's the
10 most kind of news that you read and
youtube does the same thing by the way
um
then you get more news stories and i was
spending you know an hour and a half a
day two hours a day just reading news
stories like who cares i can just read
the new york times or the guardian or
something like that and get a sense of
like what's going on that's what i need
to know i don't need to like i don't
need to be reading every single article
there is about
uh the ukraine or the seattle seahawks
right so but what this makes me think of
is humanity back in the day you know
when we were cavemen or when primitive
society
you know early agricultural society or
hunter gathering or whatever like it's
like oh blackberries are in season i'm
gonna have a handful oh i got a little
bit of dopamine that's like your
dopamine for the month yes or maybe even
the year
and you know you have sex with your mate
in the cave and like there's a little
bit more
here's some i'm going to roast this deer
hoof over my fire now i got a little bit
more but
we we were not designed for this maximum
right uh dopamine overload like reza was
painting that portrait so perfectly of
like
we're never bored
um
and
uh i feel any kind of just pleasure we
can we can
it's like brave new world with soma yeah
zoma is good you know if people aren't
familiar with the reference the book by
al aldous huxley about you know where
they actually do figure out a medication
that doesn't produce the gremlins it
only produces the the lack of pain uh
without any gremlin gremlin free
so
so here we are in this situation with
non-stop algorithms uh we weren't
created for this you know it's just it's
just a flood of distraction
and soothing and escaping pain um so
what is what does this show about us
where are we headed as a species
barring of course some post-apocalyptic
horror that like you know takes us back
to just eating blackberries every once
in a while yes
yeah well i mean i i don't even think we
necessarily have to talk about where are
we headed as a species i really think
we're already there as a species
which is if you know the the the ways in
which we are
auto stimulating ourselves
um
causes so much suffering you know it
it's not it's not a matter of
depriving ourselves of things that are
really fun it's really a matter of
like people are really
suffering i mean people are really
in distress i really feel that um
you know and i and i share it right and
as a parent i see it and and
my community
i mean
it's
we're in trouble now right it's it's
it's
it's contributing to
uh
poor mental health it's contributing to
loss of life
um
i mean we're already we're there we're
there
so the big question that we're exploring
in this episode is essentially why is
everybody so damn miserable all the damn
time right right yeah um and then that's
a that's such an important question it's
a really important question it really it
really is yeah but talking to you and
and and you know listening to what
you're saying and reading this book and
the research behind it and understanding
the
intimate connection between pain and
pleasure
it seems to me that the answer
is that we can all be less miserable
if only we allowed ourselves to just be
more occasionally miserable
you know what i'm saying yeah like maybe
i'm just so obsessed with trying to
remove misery be less miserable yeah
just dwell let's dwell a little bit more
in our misery and in our boredom like
just be a little bit more bored and
miserable
let it hurt for a while and then you
will be happier like we were
in the 70s and the 80s we were a little
bit more bored and a little bit more
miserable and guess what we were happier
yeah i mean is that really is that
really the answer anna like just we can
we can be less miserable if we just
allow us ourselves to be a little more
miserable
i take the lead from my patients with
severe addiction for whom
figuring this out is a matter of life
and death
and what they have shown me is that when
they abstain
from their drug of choice
and let those gremlins hop off the pain
side of the balance the reward
resets itself
they achieve
dopamine homeostasis and they're able to
enjoy more modest rewards
it is the important starting place
for our own wellness and healing
is to essentially
issue these pleasures avoid them not
forever necessarily but for long enough
that we can
establish our
natural baseline a healthier baseline a
new baseline
where
we have a supple pleasure pain balance
where we're level again where we can
do something like you know have a dinner
with friends or watch a sunset and it's
actually genuinely enjoyable you know we
don't have to be watching a sunset while
watching netflix while smoking pot you
know instagram
instagram
i mean it is funny how much this this is
like you know kind of like akin to
another type of you know behavior that
people do
um to pleasure themselves i just i'm i'm
sorry i hope that's not too often
wow she went there but this is so funny
that's bad i really we're gonna get you
discard from stanford university for
that crap
i mean to be perfectly honest like a lot
of our episodes you know we ask these
questions but we never answer them yeah
or if we do answer them the answers
aren't very satisfying this one
just makes
a lot of weird counter-intuitive sense
great i'm glad because i've got more
i've got more so so avoid
yes i want to hear them more okay but is
what you're talking about and just
insert this in there um
no pun intended uh is some of this
dopamine fasting
this is dopamine fasting this is
dopamine as you're talking about right
so so let me just say like when when i
talk about dopamine fasting what i mean
is to choose that one or two things that
we have a frequent relationship with and
eliminate that for 30 days so it's not
everything that gives some kind of
reinforcement question you can do that
but that's that's not really what i'm
talking about that's not the recipe that
i recommend what i say is choose that
one or two things for me it was romance
novels
get it out of your house or whatever it
takes for 30 days okay why 30 days in my
clinical experience 30 days is the
minimum amount of time it takes to
restore baseline homeostasis that is to
say for those gremlins to hop off the
pain side of the balance and for your
balance to be level again
i also always tell patients the first
two weeks or hell it feels like it will
never end you're anxious you're
depressed you're craving right you can't
imagine you'll get to a place where this
is even remotely worth it why because it
takes a while for those gremlins to hop
off they don't hop off right away they
like it on the balance but if you
continue to avoid your drug of choice
eventually they'll go ah and they'll go
off and off and eventually your make
your way and by weeks three and four
about eighty percent of folks feel a
whole lot better if they come back at
week four and they don't feel better
that's also really useful information
because it says okay there's something
else going on here maybe this person has
a major depressive disorder maybe you
know there's some other biological
um you know malady that we need to
identify
and then once folks get to that 30 days
they feel so much better i no longer
have to sell this project they have now
bought into it because they see it in
their own
experience and that is just awesome
right because then it's like oh wait i
get it now like i felt like smoking pot
was alleviating my anxiety but actually
now i've abstained for 30 days my
anxiety is better than it has been in
years the pot was actually making me
anxious and many many many such stories
so um that's my prescription really for
for for starters now the second piece of
it is if you remember this balance when
we do things that are pleasurable so
that initial stimulus tilts us to
pleasure those gremlins hop on the pain
side
but likewise if the initial stimulus is
pain
those gremlins are agnostic to which
side they hop on they're going to hop on
the pleasure side and we're going to get
a little tilt to the side of pleasure
why
because pain or really any noxious
stimulus from discomfort to
actual physical pain is a signal to the
body that we need to start to upregulate
our own feel-good neurotransmitters and
hormones because there's an injury right
so then our little dopamine factor
factories start like making more
dopamine right so we actually get our
dopamine indirectly and that is a much
more enduring form so if you just
visualize dopamine spike if we use an
intoxicant a pleasurable stimulus it
spikes up and then immediately goes down
below baseline levels into this dopamine
deficit state whereas if the initial
stimulus is pleasurable what we get is a
slow rise in dopamine over the course of
that painful stimulus whether it's nice
cold water bath or exercising or
whatever the heck it is
and then even when we're done and
especially when we're done with that
pain those dopamine levels remain
elevated for hours afterwards and we
have a lot of good evidence to show that
so a much better way to get your
dopamine is indirectly
so but and and just repeat that a little
bit because i got a little bit lost so
how do you start that
that event that slow dopamine release
you start it with a with a painful event
or just kind of a more moderate uh
pleasurable event
ah okay so the key is that
so if you think about things that are
potentially addictive there are things
that once we start them we don't want
them to end
whereas there are other activities we
can do is once we start them we just
can't wait till they're over
that's things like exercise now of
course there's that rare animal out
there who will tell you i love to
exercise it feels great but most of us
are like this is a slog
i really am going to be happy when this
is over or they go into an ice cold
water bath ouch this really hurts i'm
really going to be happy when this is
over
so
those are the fundamental differences
that we're talking about and when we do
things that are hard in the moment
what we get is a gradual increase in
dopamine
as we're doing that activity as the
body's trying to protect us from injury
and then those levels remain elevated
even after we've completed that just to
use a concrete example
a
fascinating study where they immersed
adults in an ice cold water bath
measured dopamine serotonin
norepinephrine levels over the course of
the water bath and again saw this
gradual rise in dopamine over the one
hour course and then dopamine levels
remaining
in that heightened place for hours after
they were out of the bath before finally
returning back to tonic baseline levels
does that make sense and that's in
contrast to an intoxicant where you get
that sudden spike
right but then the sudden drop and then
the dopamine deficit state that's the
price we pay but we don't usually see
the connection between those two things
and then with repeated exposure to an
intoxicant we eventually settle out at a
new lower baseline
so you when you were talking about this
this seesaw of pain and pleasure and
slow release of dopamine i thought about
the buddha and i thought about buddhism
and the central idea that life is
suffering you know in the original
sanskrit it was the word was dukkha and
that meant
it means not just suffering means
irritant
um
something that makes you miserable
something that's annoying something that
makes you sad it's not just like
suffering in the in the grandest
concept but life is dukkha
and the the way around that and from the
buddhist principles is detachment or
non-attachment from the things of this
world it's because we're clutching we're
grasping we're wanting yes that that is
creating dukkha so really wasn't the
buddha talking about this kind of this
dopamine seesaw
yes the buddha plato and socrates i mean
it's woven throughout theological texts
this is actually just very old wisdom
recycled for the age of neuroscience but
i would say and i do say this in the
book that even buddha's middle way
may not be enough for the world that we
live in now because we're so inundated
with dopamine at every turn that we may
actually have to choose
pain
as a way to navigate this really insane
ecosystem oh my god choose pain besides
the pain of ice baths
get up in the morning and roll around
and like garlic
a hair shirt
and uh yeah hair shirts and flagellation
and eat some dirt and then and then and
then start your day well you know i
think everybody needs a different level
of intensity and honestly for the modern
person
just unplugging for an hour is so
painful um that that may be
all that they need to do in order to
begin to reset reward pathways i cannot
tell you how many young people in
particular i have talked to and
suggested that they just put their
device away for 24 hours and the notion
of that
sends them into an absolute panic yeah
and i just it makes me feel super old
yeah
dr lemke this has been an absolutely
brilliant amazing conversation i've
gotten so much out of it i think our
listeners
uh all 407 of them will
as well
and um but we end every episode with
what we call the lightning round of
life's big questions we're going to
throw some life's big doozy questions
your way we want to hear your personal
response the first thing that comes into
your head okay
and your lightning fast response to some
of these questions so
describe your soul in 10 words or less
my soul is the membrane between the
universe and my
inner consciousness
boom
that's actually i think the
exact definition
of the soul well done spot on um what
skill do you wish you had
i wish i were good at music
what is something that very very few
people know about you
ah very few people know that our first
child died of leukemia
i'm so sorry to hear that that's
heavy and tragic and difficult i'm very
sorry
what emotion do you wish you could
better control anger
me too sister
[Laughter]
what is one eye-opening experience every
person should have
i hate to say be cliched about it but
um
i guess it would be that the more we try
to run from our pain the faster it finds
us
[Music]
besides romance novels uh what's one
thing that uh
you just can't live without i mean
in a fun way i don't mean like literally
in the way that we've been discussing
and now that i asked this question i
realized the total inappropriate yes
right of it but let's just pretend
uh
well
i would say the one thing i really
couldn't live without is my kids
and i'll throw my husband in there too
all right
that's nice
if you could interview anyone living or
dead who would it be and what would you
ask them
oh
so
res i read your book on god and
i
i mean i would really love to interview
someone like jesus christ or buddha i'd
really like to meet those people in
person because i think i would discover
they were really ordinary
people and i would just love to confirm
that
um
[Music]
and i guess the other thing i i'm
just now in this moment one of the
things that i was fascinated in about in
your book was this
cave painting of a human animal
form
and you know you you said that there's
all this evidence that the cave painting
actually represents a deity to them but
i thought to myself
what if it was just their equivalent of
a superhero
oh yeah like it was like they're you
know cineplex yeah the lord of beasts
yeah so i guess i'd be curious i'm
curious about it i i you know honestly
i'm not sure if they would make any
distinction between god and superhero
there you go there and when maybe we
don't either and
i think
today's young people don't worship god
they actually worship uh marvel's
avengers well that's exactly right
that's exactly right when do you feel
most connected to the universe
probably when i'm seeing patients and
feeling like i'm being of service that's
a very
wonderful inflow moments for me
and then last but not least uh what is
your life's big question
oh my life's i have so many big
questions for life i i i'm curious about
whether or not we have the ability to
choose
i wonder if there's a god
um i care about truth and justice and i
want to know what's true and what's just
i i have too many questions well please
please email them all to us we're
running out of show ideas yes thank you
if you have the answers please we'll
pare it down for you we'll narrow it
down to you thank you good question
that's a service we provide
uh dr anna lemke thank you so much for
being with us what a scintillating
conversation uh folks make sure to pick
up this book
dopamine
nation
fascinating um
fascinating stuff and um
thank you for joining us well thank you
this was really fun
so reza um
what do you think dopamine fast
you know
it makes sense to me this whole like
you know you can stop being so miserable
by being a little bit more miserable uh
so so if i were to do a dopamine fast
what would it be what would it be what
would my dopamine fast
be
um
it's tough it's tough uh you tell me
yours first well could you no i'm gonna
give you one
could you go
could you go one hour
between
nine and five could you go one hour
between nine and five without a
email or text or twitter
i can go one hour
uh could i go
three hours
i would start to feel it then could i go
the whole day no
no i don't think so well you got you
mean you gotta you gotta make some bread
and butter for your for your family
there yeah not you know
but but i don't need social media to do
that so could i go could i go 30 days
without social media without when i say
social media like i'm on like the tick
tock
basically i'm just on twitter
but you're on twitter just reading the
tweets of people that you agree with
and retweeting them and saying yeah
yeah
ditto
i mean i think my version of a dopamine
first of all is my screen time is just
through the roof i don't know how many
hours per day this phone is on in my
hand drives my wife crazy
uh certainly but but you know i liked
what she was saying about like the cold
plunge and there was a while earlier on
in the pandemic when i was like
exercising in the mornings with some
weight training which sucks and it's the
worst and it sucks and it's awful and i
hate it and then i was going and sitting
in our cold swimming pool
um
and and and i did i felt it i felt the
difference
i had more productive days i had more
uh calm days i i i felt a greater sense
of peace and well-being and she talked
about human flourishing and i love that
phrase eudaimonia the ancient greeks
called it the pursuit of human
flourishing and i flourished better when
i did that so
i don't know about a dopamine fast
although i certainly need to put my
phone down more but a little bit of pain
in the morning perhaps will uh set me
off on on the toward the pleasure
principle
all right i'm only i'm willing to try it
i'm i'm willing to do a 30-day
no twitter fast
30-day no twitter
30 day no twitter are we hearing this
right now folks
this is it folks i'm gonna do it 30 days
so make sure to follow at reza at aslan
yes so on that note if you have a life's
big question send me a tweet about it
and i will not look at it for 30 days uh
you can find me on social at reza aslan
you can find rain rainwilson and you can
find the podcast at meadowmilkpodcast
and on instagram which i also will not
be looking at at metaphysical milkshake
let us know your life's question and at
the very least rain might respond
hey folks
welcome back to the tail end of this
episode we recorded a little while ago
with anna lemke
uh all about dopamine nation and the
dopamine in our brains but of course you
know that you've just heard the podcast
but we're coming back to this podcast a
month later because
reza aslan my co-host
uh
decided he pledged he committed to doing
a dopamine fast a twitter dopamine fast
for one month
yeah
at the conclusion of that pod here we
are a month later it is now early march
reza aslan how did it go
i feel like i can see the world again
don't be serious you're brighter
be serious no i'm just no i'm not no but
but i will say this um you gave up
twitter for a month i gave up all social
media all social media for a month a
month and you used to on twitter you
used to
ten times a day
for five to ten years
yeah yeah uh pretty active i'm pretty
active on on twitter i i gotta be honest
with you i i uh i was not looking
forward to it
but i knew that the whole point was to
not look forward to it
um
and then of course this is so on the
first day of my social media fast my
football team
the raiders always will be known as the
oakland raiders to me
uh hired an entire new coaching staff
and i'm like oh
i can't
get involved on like the third day
my nemesis my bet noir
jeff zucker uh former president of
fired for having an affair
yeah gets in a scandal is fired and i
can't gloat
i'm like i all i want to do is gloat
right now
and i can't gloat
and then like on the second week russia
it starts the largest land war in europe
since 1939 and i'm like jesus christ
this is not the time to be off of social
media but i did it i did it
uh what did it do to me i well i was
bored more often i will say that the
first couple of weeks were weird because
like for no reason at all i would pick
up my phone i'd be like feeding my
daughter and then i would just pick up
my phone
almost automatically
to to go on twitter for some stupid
reason and then realize oh i don't have
twitter on my phone and then i put the
phone down
so that was that was nice here's here's
i think the the the fundamental takeaway
and i haven't gone back yet i will soon
after this podcast i will go back
is that um
fundamentally
i didn't
miss it
which was weird
you know like at no point that i think
to myself
like even with all of these amazing
events going on in the world all these
amazing things i you know i found myself
knowing less about what the hell is
happening you know how was your how was
your anxiety state or emotional state
any any differences there that's
interesting yeah no i i did i did feel
better about things calmer about things
i mean i certainly would have been a lot
angrier were you more you were more you
can get very agita around yeah i get
agitated very easily by by world events
you know kevin mccarthy says something
stupid and i'm like that [ __ ]
and then i start yelling at my kids for
no reason and they're like why are you
angry and i was like it's not you it's
something the minority leader in the
house
who has nothing to do with me whatsoever
did that made me angry so that was that
was nice
um
yeah i mean honestly i think that was
the biggest thing that the two biggest
impacts on my life was
i was bored more often but
it was okay it was i was okay sometimes
just being bored and be like i got
nothing to do i'm gonna stare out the
window that was nice
yeah haven't been i haven't been bored
in a very long time
you know basically since i got my phone
i haven't been bored
and then
uh
i had i you know i i my poops took a lot
less time
[Laughter]
so my my my wife appreciated that part
you know she'd have to be like why are
you still in the bathroom you weren't in
the for the 12 minute poop so you did
the four minute poop
yeah there was just like nothing to do
there's just nothing to do with poop so
you know
there you have it so um yeah
folks uh reza put it to a try uh
will you
what do you think quiet people 30 days
30 days no social media what do you
think you can give up um
i'm gonna give up cocaine so
30 for 30 days jesus yeah for 30 days
thanks for listening metaphysical
milkshake is executive produced by rayne
wilson reza aslan and colin thompson it
is produced by safa samazadeh yazd
harris lane mick demaria hashem self and
dj lubell
cast media is the production and
distribution partner original music by
jeff tang
if hollywood was making a biopic about
your life uh what would it be called and
who would play you
oh that's scary um
it would probably be called
a
psychiatrist swimming against the stream
and
um
maybe rayne wilson would play me
i'd see that i could do it yeah yeah
i'm up to that minus the beard
well i don't know
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you